pleasure to meet you sereno de bergerac
you're a freak
freak
[Music]
my dearest friend be very angry with you
if you died
my sole purpose on this earth is to love
roxanne does she know the world will
never accept someone like me and a tall
beautiful woman
we have no money a clever marriage is
your only option i won't be rescued i'm
not in distress love does that mean
nothing to you children need love adults
need money
i need something to die for
write bones and cry for and i won't be
ashamed
i'd give anything
for someone to say
that they can't live without me
i have a confession to make i am madly
in love perhaps he feels the same but
i've never actually spoken to him of
your love i think
he is christian christian neville he's a
new recruit your regiment of course he
is a woman like roxanne wants wit
romance poetry i don't know how to speak
romantically i am a poet my words upon
your lips
i will make you romantic while you make
me handsome
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
speak to me like you do in your letters
you are a beautiful flower i am not a
flower i need more
my fate is to love her from afar
[Music]
we must let her decide our fate she must
have the choice
[Music]
you